>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: Hey.
Welcome. Welcome to the Teen Board.
And our 2016 author visit.
We're very excited.
Meg Medina is a very dear friend
of the Young Reader's Center
and the Library of Congress.
She's -- thank you -- she's been
to our national book festival,
and she's coming again this year.
And she's participated
in a symposium
that we had last year on diversity.
And she's leading and participating
in a symposium next month
on immigration and
children's literature.
So, we're all very
excited to have her.
And while she does, she's
an award-winning author,
who produces a lot of
about picture books.
But she also produces
a lot of YA books.
And you will be very lucky to
be receiving a copy of The Girl
Who Could Silence The Wind
at the end of the program.
And she will be signing
these for you.
And why she's signing
them, surprise.
While she's signing them, Kathy will
pick up on the previous conversation
and talk a little bit about
some new books that she has,
so that you can take something else
away to read, besides this book,
which you'll probably read first.
Two books that you
might be familiar with.
That you've heard from Kathy.
Yaqui Delgado Wants
to Kick Your Ass.
And her recent book, that just
came out, Burn Baby, Burn.
So, I'm just going the give
the program over to Meg Medina,
and feel free, when it's
appropriate, to ask her questions.
And I think you'll
enjoy the program.
Thanks.
>> Meg Medina: Can you guys all here
me okay, if I'm just talking here?
Okay, that's great.
So, first of all, the is the middle
of April, which means that the end
of the school year is in sight.
Yay. You made it.
It's within reach, people.
So. Congratulations.
I always love spring, and during
the school year, because I feel
like it's almost there, that
it's time to rest and to stop.
And Karen's right, that I love to
come to the Young Reader's Center,
because I think the Library
of Congress is probably one
of the most beautiful
buildings I've ever seen.
All in celebration to knowledge
and book, which is really
where people's power is to be found.
So, I'm, every time I get
an invitation, I don't,
I don't even listen very
carefully to the invitation.
I say yes, of course,
I'd be happy to be there.
So, today I'm going to
just introduce myself,
just a little bit about my books.
Just very briefly.
And then we're going to talk about
the newest one that came out.
But I do want to tell
you about the one
that you're getting as a present.
So, I write fiction for all ages.
Sometimes I write picture books.
Sometimes I write middle-grade
fiction.
Sometimes I write YA.
It just depends on my mood.
And the story.
So, for my picture books, when
I'm wanting to feel like joyous
and happy and full of light,
I write a picture book.
Because, you know what a
four and a five and a six
and a seven-year-old is like.
These are the people who go to the
grocery store in a Superman outfit.
Or, like a tutu.
For no reason.
You've got to love that.
So, I write a picture book
when I'm feeling hopeful.
But, when I'm feeling, like,
I really want to explore
something a little bit harder.
When I'm feeling snarky.
When I'm feeling fed up.
When I'm feeling like I'm on my last
nerve, I turn to fiction for you.
Young adult fiction.
And I love it because I think
teens ask hard questions.
I think teens smell a rat easily.
I think that teens
are really discerning.
So, I like to write
stories that sort
of capture the experience
of growing up.
The beautiful parts of it,
and the funny parts of it,
and also the really
awful parts of it.
So, most people know me in YA
for a book called Yaqui
Delgado Wants to Kick Your Ass.
What do you think was the biggest
problem that I had with that book?
Shall we guess?
Right. It was the title, of course.
It was always the first
line of the book.
Always, always.
But I had not put that on the title.
Because I felt bad for librarians.
That was the first thing.
And also, because I couldn't
picture them saying, " Welcome,
Meg Medina to our school.
Author of ..."
and you know, I just
couldn't picture like how
that was going to go in a school.
And also because my mother was
alive, and she lived with me,
and I was like, how am I going
to tell my 88-year-old mother
that this is the title of book?
So, I felt very bad about it.
But, in the end, I'm
very glad that the book,
that the title is what it is.
Because the book names the
experience of bullying, I think,
the way it actually looks.
And it names the experience like
what happens to us when randomly,
out of nowhere, somebody targets us.
How does a girl unravel?
And more importantly, how does a
girl sew herself back together.
Because, as all of you know,
sitting out there, you know,
middle school and high school.
It's not for the weak.
And every day is sometimes,
can feel like an onslaught
of little insults and big insults.
Small hurts and hurts that
you'll about for years
and years into your life.
And so, when I wrote that back, I
decided to go back into my own life,
and remember when a girl in a rabbit
fur coat came up to me and said,
"Yaqui Delgado is going
to kick your ass."
And everything that happened to me,
and then I made up
a bunch of things.
But what was true what the
feeling of feeling lost,
and having to figure out
who I was as a Latina.
Who I was as a girl.
And how I was going to protect
myself and set up boundaries.
And you probably have to do that
yourself, every day at school.
So, the other book that I
wrote that's YA is this one,
The Girl Who Could Silence The Wind.
I always call it the book
that almost killed Meg Medina.
Because, it was my first YA.
And, how many of you
out here like to write?
In your own time?
Okay. So, you know that
feeling, when you're trying
to get it right, and you can't.
Okay. That was the
story of this book.
I rewrote that book
about seven times.
Each time, trying to
get it closer and closer
to the kind of book that I wanted.
I wanted to write a magical realism.
Because it's such a gift from
Latin American, in literature.
I wanted to write a story
about why people migrate.
Because that's the conversation
in our country right now.
There's so much conversation about
who's coming to this country.
And immigrants.
And I wanted to tell the story
about why people move,
and what's at stake.
And so, I kept writing
it, and kept failing.
My agent said it was
terrible, and she sent me back
to rewrite it a couple of times.
My editor kept saying well,
let's try one more time.
Let's try one more time.
It ended up being seven.
In the end, I have loved this book.
I will tell you that it's sad.
So, be prepared.
And I am going the
apologize ahead of time.
I'm sorry, I had to do it.
Once you read the book,
this will all make sense.
I had to do it.
I had to do it, and I won't
tell you what that "it" is,
because the journey to
get to this country is
in fact a violent and dangerous one.
And I felt loo like
if I softened it,
that I wouldn't be
telling the truth.
And the thing is, that
when you write for teens,
if you write for young people,
I think the deal that you make
with your readers is that
you're going to tell the truth.
Even though you're making a
fiction up, a piece of fiction,
you have to tell the truth
about the human experience.
For that kid, privately, to be
able to sit, you, in your room,
or in your library, or
whenever you like to read,
and say that's exactly right.
Or that's how it feels.
Or, oh my gosh, I never
thought about it that way.
So, I'm sorry.
You'll have to tell me.
You'll have to write to me on e-mail
and so on about what you thought.
And then, I come to
Burn, Baby, Burn.
So, when I say "burn, baby, burn",
what do you think of immediately?
What comes to your mind?
As soon as I say "burn, baby, burn"?
Most people go oh.
What is it?
Raise you hand if you know.
Khadid? [assumed spelling]
>> Khadid: Disco inferno.
>> Meg Medina: Disco inferno, yes.
Disco music.
All right.
So. Here's the thing, people.
I grew up in Queens, New York.
And I was 13 in 1977.
I'm pretty old.
Remain calm.
So, disco was all over
the air waves.
1977 in New York.
You know, if you say to a
New Yorker, of a certain age,
my age and older, " Oh, yeah.
1977. This is the face
they all make.
It's like this revulsion.
This horror.
And you don't know why.
But people who lived
through it though why.
And I'm going to take
you on a little journey
into what New York City
looked like in 1977.
42nd Street, which is today
Times Square, which is a place
where people go the get their
picture taken with Belle, or Beauty
and the Beast, or to go to the
Wax Museum, was in fact a triple-
X rated place where people could go
and see half-naked women dancing,
and buy horrible magazines.
There was a lot of prostitution,
and there was an enormous amount
of drug activity on the street.
So, when I was a student, even
years later at Hunter College,
years later, they would give us free
tickets, or student-rate tickets,
to go see shows on
Broadway for very little.
Like 10 bucks, or 15 bucks.
Some ridiculous amount of money.
But you'd be afraid to go.
Because you had to got on
the subway, and get out in
that part of town and navigate.
And it was scary.
The subways were covered
in graffiti.
The city was bankrupt.
So, I do remember that
teachers would get their checks
on Friday and go sprinting.
I want you to picture
your teachers doing this.
Right to the bank,
to cash their check,
because they weren't sure the
city would have funds to pay them.
So, that was a huge stress.
It looked like that on
the inside of the subway.
And it smelled like urine.
That is the memory that I had,
sitting in there, like
a dusty urine.
People would defecate in the subway.
People were sleeping on the subway.
It was, it looked like this.
But then there was disco music.
And, not only disco music.
Look at this ticket.
This is the band Queen.
Right? Look at the
price to go see them.
Where was it?
Seven dollars and 50 cents, at
Madison Square Garden, for a ticket.
Can you imagine?
So, Queen was new.
Led Zeppelin was new.
Punk rock music was new.
And it was this clash
of sound in the city.
So, you could be wearing
your platform shoes,
and your white his-and-her
matching velour jump suit,
and your glitter eye stuff,
and your hair all flipped out.
And then there was somebody
all punked out with safety pins
through their ears, and so on.
It was a whole clash.
So, it wasn't all bad.
It was the women's movement.
Ms. Magazine was five
years old that year.
And when Ms. Magazine, which is a
feminist magazine, first came out,
people said, who's going
to buy that magazine?
Are you crazy?
It'll be out of business
by the end of the year.
It was celebrating
its fifth anniversary.
Bella Abzug had, was
running for Mayor that year.
And this is how she
decided to launch it.
She got a bull horn.
You see how she's wearing a hat?
She's famous for wearing hats.
And she had a big mouth, and a
big, big Brooklyn kind of accent.
And she got a bull
horn, and she walked
down Fifth Avenue going
" Hello, New York.
I'm running for Mayor," in
the middle of the day, right?
And the greatest thing is
that traffic stopped,
and it become a parade.
It was all a little crazy.
And this was happening.
See, this is Ms. Magazine.
And I know that now, with our
I-phones and Twitter and Facebook,
we get news immediately, and
there's nothing that's private.
But I'm here to tell
you that, in 1976,
that cover of Ms. Magazine was the
first time any major magazine had
covered violence against women.
It was shocking that anybody
would talk about this,
that anybody would say, men aren't
supposed to hit their women.
You are not supposed
to keep that secret.
So, all of these layers
were being peeled back.
I remember all of these buttons.
Everybody was fighting for
the Equal Rights Amendment.
But this is mostly what a remember.
That, in the middle of all of that,
girls started to turn up dead.
And they were young women.
18 years old.
19, 20, 25.
Who were out on dates
with their boyfriends.
And someone would shoot
into the car.
And it started to happen sort
of in the early fall,
and then more and more.
And what we didn't know,
because this was pre-Twitter,
and all of that, is what
the police already suspected
that it was one man.
One sane guy, who was
shooting with a .44.
So, we called him the
44- Caliber Killer.
Until he started to write
letters to the newspaper.
These long, rambling
love letters to New York.
I'm still here.
I'm going to get you on Friday.
Don't think I'm sleeping.
And he'd write them
to the newspaper.
And newspapers are in the
business of selling news papers.
So, this was huge.
So, they started to publish them.
I, I'm sorry to give it away,
that it ended up being him.
Which was such a disappointing
thing, when he was finally arrested.
He worked for the Post Office.
They arrested David
Berkowicz, was his name.
They arrested him walking
to his car.
He had a little brown lunch sack
in which he was holding
his.44 caliber gun.
And an entire man hunt, a
year-long man hunt had been funded
around finding him.
All of the police officers
who had been laid off,
because of the city's
financial crisis,
had been rehired to find him.
And he had the city crazy.
Girls were dyeing their hair,
because he liked dark-haired girls.
So, they would dye their hair
blond, or would be wearing hats.
You wouldn't go out after dark.
It was a panic.
This was one of the first
young women, Christine Freund.
She was killed with her fiance.
And then, these are some
samples of his letters.
And they were rambling.
They were crazy, crazy letters.
And then, of course, you could
see all the different headlines
that were going on at the time.
But for a kid who's 13,
every day, to ask who's dead.
And these thing were happening,
sometimes blocks from where I lived.
His first shooting was,
he, I think made a mistake.
It was on Depo Road, sort of
near where our building was.
Maybe six or seven blocks.
And the person who ended
up hurt was the young men.
But he had long hair.
He had long brown hair.
So, we think David Berkowicz
assumed he was the girl.
Because he was sitting
in the passenger's seat.
The war belonged to the young woman.
Who, as it turns out,
was the daughter
of a detective at the
107th Precinct.
That was the headquarters
of operational Mega,
which was his, the
task force for him.
You know, we just got really scared.
And people started
to do crazy things.
There was a hotline set up.
So, the hotline was always
clogged with people saying
"I think it's my brother.
It's my father.
I'm sure it's my sixth-grade
teacher."
You know, like all of this stuff.
Everybody throwing
people under the bus.
And, of course, every
headline was this.
So, we were panicked.
Interestingly, this also
happened that same year.
Yeah. New York was broke, so
they hired a marketing firm,
and they designed that campaign.
You know it.
[sings] I love New York.
And it had all the Broadway
people dancing into the camera.
I love New York.
And New Yorkers were
like, are you crazy?
We don't love New York.
We want to get out of New York.
This is a sham.
And the irony is that this
was one of the most successful
and long-lasting marketing
campaigns ever launched.
And it came at a time when
the city was imploding.
So, all of that was cooking.
Let me just see what I have.
All of that was cooking, and
the temperature was rising.
And in July, we had a heat wave.
A heat wave is a horrible
thing in brick building
that have no air-conditioning.
So, it was 98 degrees,
then it was 101 degrees,
then it was 105 degrees.
It just ticked up and ticked up.
And New Yorkers, even
on the best day,
are a little cranky
sometimes, right?
So, you can imagine, in the
heat, and with the fear,
and Son of Sam is still out.
And then, that summer night
in July, a storm happens.
A lightning strike.
And the entire city goes dark.
Manhattan, Brooklyn,
Bronx, the Queens.
All of it.
Not a single light.
Now, let me tell you something.
If you live in a small
town in the woods,
you're used to complete darkness.
Where you do this,
and you see nothing.
But there's no New
Yorker that's used
to complete silence
or complete darkness.
It doesn't actually exist
naturally in New York City.
There's always the
lights of Broadway,
the streetlights, everything.
Gone. So, what happens
to a city that's broke,
that has enormous crime.
That has fear.
Just in every part of itself,
when it suddenly goes dark.
I'm tell you what happened
this time.
Everybody went into
the streets looting.
And I mean everybody.
All kinds of people, and all kinds
of neighborhoods were looting.
So, there were no alarms
on the stores, right?
So, you could break.
And if it wasn't nailed
down, people took it.
Everything from diapers
to groceries.
My personal favorite in the research
was people driving off new cars
from the lot.
They just drove through
the plate glass window.
And took the car, because
who was going to stop you?
It was a night of craziness, right?
And so, fires were set.
Because that year, arson
was the crime of the day.
So, I think it was like
1000 fires was set.
This is the scene of a hospital
that night, and you can see,
people are getting hurt by shattered
glass, and everything else.
Yeah. 1000 fires were reported.
3700 people were arrested.
And, in total, it was $
300 million in damages.
After that event, I mean,
I think the city just had
to do so much soul-searching.
So, I'm here to tell you
that I was 13 that summer.
That year.
And all of that went inside.
And as young writers, you know,
or maybe you don't know, just yet,
that everything you live on
a daily basis comes inside
and has the potential
to become a work
of art inside you,
or a book inside you.
And I never did forget that year.
How afraid I was.
How scary the city was.
And how hard it was to be young,
and just happy, against a backdrop
of stuff that was truly,
truly scary.
So, I decided, okay.
I'm going to see if can
write this next novel.
I'm going to set it
in 1977 in New York.
It's like, what's the story?
It's impossible to pick, like, which
thing I was going to write about.
So, I would come to
the paper sometimes,
and I would start writing.
It was more feminist.
And then sometimes I would write
mostly about the Son of Sam things.
And then, I kept getting lost.
And, a couple of things
came forward.
The first thing was that I didn't
want to used Son of Sam murders
in a way that was insensitive
to the families
of these young people
who were gunned down.
They still have people who think of
them, and love them, and miss them.
And I didn't want to
make it entertainment.
So, that was one consideration.
Toning that down, making it scary,
but not making it the focus.
And then, my editor
said to me, listen.
If you make it the
story of the girl.
I always write with a
strong girl main character.
If you make it the
story of the girl,
and everything else is her world,
whatever is true for her is true.
It's the story.
So, stay focused on her.
So, I made Nora Lopez,
who's 17 that year.
And she's falling in love.
Or wants to, or wants to date
this person who's asking her out.
But she's scared to
death to be in a car
with this guy virtually anywhere.
But in addition, as I was getting
to know Nora, as I was writing her,
I realized that Nora had
some secrets of her own.
And that there was violence outside,
but there was also violence inside.
And that's when things got tricky.
Because the story is really
about something called
juvenile domestic violence.
So, when we think about
violent homes, we often think
that it's the adult being
violent to the child.
That's usually how
it works, actually.
But, not always.
Sometimes we have violent children.
Sometimes a brother
is really violent,
or a sister is really violent to the
other siblings, or to the parents.
The thing about that is that
people tend to keep that secret.
Because there's shame
involved in it.
Parents don't like to talk about it,
because they feel like, you know,
they have no control over their
children, or what does this say
about their parenting
skills, et cetera.
Kids doesn't like to talk about it,
because they're afraid
of their siblings.
Right? And so, it's shrouded
in sort of this secrecy.
And then, in Latino families,
because I'm often writing
about families that are
from other countries,
and people speak different
languages, and so on.
There was some really hard things.
Like, mental health is a hard
thing to have, like, to pay for.
The medicine, the therapy.
All of those things, if you
don't have the money to do so.
Mental health services
are hard to access
if you can't find a psychiatrist
that speaks the same language.
Or who understands, like,
the nuances of your culture.
Right? So, I had to throw
all of that at Nora.
To really figure out
what she was going to do,
about violence outside
and violence inside.
So, the interesting part, as
I was writing this, some days,
I was saying this to myself.
And I said it same thing
when I was writing The Girl
Who Could Silence The Wind.
When I got to that part
that we can't discuss yet.
I said, why would I do
this to young people?
Why am I going to write this
just terribly sad, scary thing?
Don't read this aloud.
Like, that kind of thing.
Why would I do this?
And so, I gave that
a lot of thought.
And I started to think
about, what is it about 1977
that has anything to do with you?
In 2016? Like, who cares.
I wonder if I have
the picture of, yeah.
I mean, do you really
want to go back to this?
I don't know.
How do you make this cool?
So, yeah. I know.
I know. The shoes are,
in particular.
They're really something.
But, I kept wrestling with that.
Like, why would somebody
your age care?
And then, I started to close my eyes
and think about your day, every day.
And I thought to myself,
well, when I was 13,
I never had to do a sniper drill.
When I was 13, I never thought
that somebody could become
dangerous in my own school.
When I was 13, I didn't worry
if somebody had packed something
very dangerous in a backpack,
to hurt us at a bus
stop, or here or there.
So, there was some, some of
that random violence of then,
I think you know exactly
what that feels like now.
And somehow, it becomes
a part of your wallpaper.
It doesn't stop you from
getting up and going to school.
laughing in the lunchroom.
It doesn't stop you from
having friends and going out.
And yet, it's part
of your wallpaper.
So, you know, I saw
commonalities there.
And then, certainly in the
70s, unfortunately, you know,
drugs was a huge part of
the whole disco scene.
And drugs continued
to be a big problem
in all of our communities now.
So, I did see, like
there were through lines,
from one period of
time to the other.
So, that's how I wrote this book.
I just, I kept my focus on Nora.
I did historical research
like crazy.
I was next door, in fact, at
the James Madison Library,
that building, looking
for, because I couldn't --
not every library has every
old newspaper and magazine.
You have to go hunting, right?
So, I went all over where I
live now, in Richmond, Virginia.
And I couldn't find, like, the
Daily News, the New York Post.
They didn't have those.
So, I had to train up here, two
hours, and sit in the microfiche,
[ Imitates buzzing ]
You know, with that silly machine,
trying to figure it all out.
And what I decided to do was
to scare myself all over again.
So, I sat down, and I started
reading the newspaper every day,
basically, right?
In live time, to see what
the story would feel like.
Here's the amazing part.
Like, in some days, I
was like, but it's him.
You know, like you're frustrated,
because you know what
people don't know yet.
And you're like, it's him, it's him.
Don't go there.
And you're so worried about
what's going to happen,
and you know it's going to happen.
And then, I felt terrified,
all over again.
I felt really nervous, especially
when David Berkowicz began all
that letter-writing campaign.
And you really got a glimpse
into his mindset, at that time.
That's always a scary place.
I want to tell you,
he's still alive.
He's serving his life sentences,
and he's in upstate New York,
where he is a model
prisoner, they say.
So, it's, I even found
footage of him in recent years.
He looks like an old guy that
you'd get into the elevator with.
I'm not kidding.
It's really kind of creepy.
But, here he was, this monster guy.
The monster of our imagination,
who was in effect a post guy.
A Post Office guy.
Who was doing all of this.
So, anyway, that's, that's how
I grappled with the big story.
But, I have, I think you
guys have arcs, maybe?
So, you have arcs.
And do you know what arcs are?
Okay. So, as I write a
book, it goes in stages.
I start with a manuscript.
And the book takes about
two years to produce.
Right? From the time
that you give it
to your editor, and
they agree to that.
It has to get designed, they
have to find the cover person
who types it, all of that.
About six months before a
book is going to come out,
they need these things called
at advance reader copies.
ARCs. And they send them to
all the newspapers and stuff,
so that reviewers can review it.
It's not like the final
book, though.
You have to know that there
are many things it this
that are a little different from the
final book, that I did on purpose.
You know, like I, when I
was reading this, I said no.
I don't want her to use that word.
I want him.
Or, I want to add this scene.
So, there are things that are in
the arc that are still incorrect.
Because they do it
from my manuscript,
from like the first pass,
after the copy editor sees it.
So, it's not in it's final form.
But, you still do get a
general idea of the book.
So, I'm imagining you may have
some questions about writing,
even though it's late in the day,
and you have been probably
up since 7 a.m..
I'm guessing you have
some questions?
Yes? Ask away.
We have a mic, so that you
can -- I'll hold it up to you.
You can ask me anything you like.
Disco. Do I dance?
>> Question: You said you wrote
your book at least 10 to 7 times.
So, what advice could you give
to someone who's starting
to write a new book?
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
I think, here's the thing.
Perseverance is a word
that you're going to have
to like truly keep in your pocket.
Because in publishing, you're
going to be told no a lot more
than you're going to be told yes.
So, early on, at your age, the most
important thing is to read widely.
Read, read, read for
the things that,
the kind of book that
you want to write.
For the topics, the
genre that you're into.
If it's horror.
If it's romance.
If it's literary fiction.
Whatever it is.
But read widely, so you
develop an ear for the story,
and you get a sense of what
a story line looks like.
If you have any chance
to take writing classes.
Creative writing classes
in middle school
and higher school and
college, do that.
Sign up for your paper.
The best training I ever
got as a fiction writer was
when I started as a journalist.
Because I had this crusty editor,
who would like read
the first paragraph
that I wrote, and he'd say this.
This is terrible.
Nobody's going to read after this.
And he'd like throw it back at
me, and I was like [whimpering].
You know, it was a terrible thing.
And you want to just
like nurse your wounds,
but in writing, you
need crocodile skin.
You need crocodile skin.
You need to be able to write as an
artist for awhile, and then you need
to step back from it, and be
able to say, you're right.
Those first 30 pages, they stink.
Or, I'm going to change
that last chapter.
I'm going to do this or that.
And that can hurt.
You know? You really want things.
In fact, if you go on my blog,
a couple of weeks ago, I think,
I put up what the original
beginning was to this novel.
It's not what's in the book.
Originally, I started the novel
in January, because in January,
Freddie Prinz Sr, not
Junior, killed himself.
I loved Freddie Prinz.
As a Latina girl in
Queens, here he was,
this Puerto Rican guy
playing a Mexican.
In tight jeans and good
hair and puppy dog eyes.
I was like madly in love
with my television screen.
Freddie Prinz was everything.
And then, sadly, Freddie
Prinz committed suicide.
It was horrible.
The other thing that was
happening that winter
with that the temperature dropped.
It was frigid.
It was like zero.
And I lived in a building where
the super, because of gas shortages
and things like that, the
super would lower the heat.
And sometimes you wouldn't
have heat or hot water.
And I'd have to boil water to
wash my face, to get to school.
You know, the whole rigamarole.
It's just a pain.
So, I wanted to start there.
Because, like, there was something
about Freddie Prinz' death
that felt so devastating.
And then, it was like the thing that
started us on this horrible slide
for the rest of the year.
Okay, so my editor,
she's really smart.
She's 30 or so, something young.
And her name's Kate.
And Kate knows just
how to deal with me.
So, she doesn't read the
manuscript and say, yeah,
that's a stinky beginning -- like
my other editor would have done.
Nobody's gonna read this.
And give it to me.
She ignores it for a while, and
we work on all the other stuff.
And then, later, way
later, almost at the end
of the process, she
says, you know, Meg?
I feel like we should
start in the spring.
Just keep it spring to summer.
Because it's just too much time.
There's just too much going on.
It gets really diffused.
I think you should
start it in March.
And somehow, by then,
I could hear it.
If she had said that to me in the
beginning, when I was just drafting,
when I was just getting the good
ideas, I would have felt offensive.
I would have said no, I'm
not going to change it.
I like my beginning.
It's a perfect beginning.
Freddie Prinz.
You know, like I would have
had all these defensive things.
But, like, there's a time.
I think Kate very wisely knows that
there's a time to let something
that kind of stinks, stay there.
Because it's the door
into the story.
And sometimes you come in through
the back door, or the side door.
Like, not the right door.
But you get in.
You figure out the story, and
then you can back out and edit it,
and make it what you need.
So, don't be afraid of your lousy
first attempts, is what I'm saying.
Because that's all they are.
It's your way in, to
see what's there.
Is there a story here
I want to tell?
And everything is changeable.
Everything is up for change.
So, that's my advice.
Boy, is that long.
I'm so sorry.
But read. Read, would
definitely be one.
Okay. Other questions?
You pick. You pick.
Don't put me on the hot seat.
You pick.
>> Question: When did you know
you wanted to be an author?
>> Meg Medina: Well,
I was always, I was,
I liked writing, even
when I was little.
So, even in elementary school,
in third grade and fifth grade,
like I was the kid who wanted to
do the short story, or the essay.
Like, I was not the kid
who'd get the piece of paper
and go [sobs], and start crying.
Right? I did that in math, right?
If you said to me, and now it's
time to talk about sets, or,
you know, congruent angles.
I would burst into tears.
But not for essays.
I loved them.
So, there with that.
But, I tried very hard not to
be a writer for a long time.
Because my mother had come
-- here's another long story.
I am so sorry about these answers.
All right, my mother had
come from Cuba in 1962.
It's a long answer, sister.
All right.
And, as an immigrant,
there was no money.
There was no language.
There was no safety net under us.
So, my mother took
a job in a factory.
And she worked for minimum wage,
which at that time
was $ 3.65 an hour.
My mother worked in that factory
for 30 years, until she retired,
and my mother retired still
earning minimum wage at the factory.
And what she wanted, more than
anything for me, and for my sister,
with that we would be educated
women, and that we wouldn't have
to work for minimum wage
in a factory for 30 years.
So, she wanted us to have
jobs that had health benefits,
and like practical, practical
things, to make our life easier.
So we wouldn't have to always
be worried about money.
The way we were.
Always wondering how we were
going the make the rent.
Always worried if we got sick, how
we were going to get to the doctor.
Like, those are real things, right?
Unfortunately for my mother,
my sister's an artist,
and I am a writer.
We couldn't do what
she wanted us to do.
It was terrible for her.
I think she really worried.
So, I was a teacher for a while.
I loved teaching.
I taught little kids, from
third grade all the way
to high school kids,
and I loved them all.
The first year I was a teacher
in New York City public schools,
I didn't know what I was doing.
But, New York City had
a shortage of teachers.
And so, if you promised to
take 15 credits in education,
they gave you the keys and the roll
book, and they said have at it.
You know? And they gave me 36 kids.
And I'm like, they're crazy.
So, the first month of
school, I think I didn't eat.
I cried every night.
I was a mess.
And my kids mostly came from
the Dominican Republic, many,
many with no English
skills whatsoever.
Because I didn't know what I was
doing, I did all the right things
and the wrong things mixed up.
So, I went to their house
before school started.
I walked the neighborhood.
I wasn't afraid of the
neighborhood, because I grew up in
that neighborhood, right?
So, I want.
Hola, que tal?
Soy la maestra.
Let's have a cafe.
So, what's going on?
So, and meet the whole family,
and just hang with them.
I took kids to baseball.
I took kids out to lunch, for pizza.
If they were good that week.
You could be arrested for
that stuff today, right?
So, that was how I
started, as a teacher.
Then I tried to be a
journalist for a while.
I wrote public relations things.
Development, meaning raising
money for an organize.
And I was pretty good
at most of that stuff.
But I was not happy
doing that stuff.
I really wanted to be a writer.
So, when I turned 40,
I went into my boss.
I was working at a school
for kids with disabilities.
And I was having a bad day, and
I think I just lost my mind.
And I got up, and I went to the
principal, and I said, Candace,
I'm going to be quitting today.
I'm going to go write a novel.
That's what she did.
She went huh.
Like, she just said
okay, and backed away.
Because that's how we
are with artists, right?
It's hard to think of
artists as being able to --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at llc.gov.